we have a look at these and then we said
that's so pedestrian that's generalized
Matthews regions are always trying to
generalize they're like what if it's not
just you know a particular other but any
number what would you get okay and this
is where we arrived and we got this
Sigma notation which is like cool an
indeterminate linköping
and we got down to thank oh very good
but we can generalize further right 1
plus X is called them between all these
but what if it's not a 1 and the necks
could be anything
okay now keeping in mind we are in
binomial theorem so I'm gonna limit it
to two things but those two things can
be anything okay so let's just quickly
look at example let's suppose I made the
numbers let's go three minus B squared
let's go to power three that'll be
enough to illustrate it yeah so if I do
this
stay with me okay let's actually expand
this I want to see what the numbers are
and see what we can get out of it okay
so this to me looks like three B's
square what happens underneath three
months actually might be square what
happens when I square it we know how to
do this we know how to square things I
should get nine minus six B squared plus
B to power four right yes
it's recess today would be let's finish
this let's expand okay 27:18
three yep let's write on the next line
so I can get them collapsing into each
other
minus 9 plus 54 sorry wait what am i
doing doing this look sorry again minus
9 plus 6
and - it seeks right
okay let's fold it all together and see
what patterns we can notice okay - 27 9
and this guy all right what happened
this is very different from what we
noticed over here
where's Pascal's triangle big gone right
like I was expecting I was expecting a 1
3 3 1 right
ah but they are there up there right
divisible by 3 to visit by 3 the one
still there
why aren't they 1 3 3 in 1 what's going
wrong because of this guy this guy is
come into play right you can see I've
got these three is coming over here
right by the time I get to here I've got
number 3s left there's something else
what happens are the science they
alternate why do they alternate cuz I
love this guy right so you get him over
here but not here cuz it gets squared
out then you get it here right because
it's cubed in that that preserves the
negative okay so now bringing this over
- what if it was anything what if it was
something like this okay remember we
said that coefficients is still there
then see whatever okay so that first
coefficients still gonna be down okay
but what will the first term beam you
see we have lots of threes right up here
oh how many threes do I have here
I've got n of them
right okay now it's not a trick question
how many bees will I have how many how
many minus B squares are there here and
the answer is zero right and there's a
power there right and now the pattern
Falls now you can go over to the next
coefficient right how many A's who I
have one less how many bees will I have
one more right can you see it
what's the last time what's the last
time
it's en how many a zoo I have I've run
out how many bees will I have and okay
wait secret notation what do I get
coefficients it's still the same what's
different in here this is what you get
when you have ones and X's but now got
A's and B's right
how many eggs will I have to the AA term
it's up one has a minus 1/2 as n minus 2
looks like everybody's on me okay